even by recent dark standards the waters
of the Mediterranean Sea have been the
scene of frequent tragedy in 2014 as
poor and desperate people put their
lives at risk to find sanctuary in
Europe for anywhere from fifteen hundred
to three and a half thousand dollars
those fleeing conflict or poverty and
looking for a better future can take
their chances in a rickety boat or an
overcrowded rubber dinghy criminal
handlers bad weather and plain bad luck
brings some of those trips to a deadly
end Members Only social media pages are
being used to attract would-be migrants
for this most dangerous kind of travel
it's a problem that doesn't look like
disappearing soon trafficking human
beings is a very lucrative business so
illegal immigrants
unfortunately they pay a lot of money to
come to Europe they lose their lives
some of them in the end endeavor and the
traffickers make money so it's not only
a mission of rescuing Nazi people who
drown the Silesia a - well a police
mission to try to dismantle a
trafficking networks the drowning of
almost 300 people of the Italian island
of Lampedusa a year ago has been a
driving force for change the European
Union set up the task force
Mediterranean it's identified five steps
to confront the challenge better border
surveillance hitting the human
traffickers who are only interested in
money
improved legal avenues to settle in the
EU and greater solidarity with partners
under high migration pressure closer
cooperation with countries that people
leave or transit to get to Europe is
another key action area Libya is the
prime example with growing numbers of
people gathering along coastal areas in
a country whose institutions have
collapsed the --use external borders
Agency Frontex monitors the flows of
would-be migrants frontex is made up of
national contributions of assets like
patrol boats or aircraft
the bulk of search-and-rescue work the
actual saving of lives is carried out by
Member States Coast Guard's and navies
in the waters off Italy which more than
100,000 people have tried to cross so
far this year the government launched a
special operation to deal with the
problem the emergency measure dubbed
Amara Nostrum is costing the Italian
government 9 million euros a month its
aims to find and rescue people in
distress and provide humanitarian
assistance as the head of the Italian
fleet explains my nostril treat symptoms
it's not a cure
this mission is too big for only one
nation for only one member state and in
any case Marino's trauma is not the
solution to the illegal immigration this
is an emergency reaction to an answer
the security at sea and to save people
from their destiny marine Ostrom is due
to be phased out this year even though
the services it provides will still be
needed meanwhile Italy's reception
capacity for asylum seekers is being
stretched to the limit to combat the
problem the European Commission and
frontex are working to merge two Frontex
missions into a new operation codenamed
Triton it will not replace marine Ostrom
but helped to boost surveillance near
Italy calls have gone out for Member
States to participate in the new venture
to commit personnel equipment and
resources on the European side funding
has also been requested member states
alone they cannot do it frontex alone
they cannot do it so we need to
cooperate all of us together to try and
put a stop to this terrible drama in the
months ahead the 28 EU partners will
have a chance to demonstrate their
commitment to this key migration
challenge and to beating the criminal
networks that profit from poverty and
conflict